Nicole Kidman ripped and completely
unrecognizable I love being shaped
molded pushed and stretched and the
actress molded into this look for a new
spread in perfect magazine rocking a
short skirt and colorful tank top
putting major focus on her jacked arms
abs and legs we see that Flex Nicole wow
I'm still around and we can't help but
notice her long red dresses in the shot
because it's given us total Practical
Magic vibes
yep that's right I'm back
hang on to your husband's girls
and while we love Nicole the actress we
are living for Nicole the model the
Oscar Winner's latest serve comes just a
month after she turned heads on the
catwalk
[Music]
work Nicole she joined Kim Kardashian
and Dua LIPA on the runway in Paris for
the Balenciaga show and sure they're all
superstars but hey sometimes even they
get nervous
yes
thankfully no Runway mishaps and Nicole
she strutted like a pro in her silver
gown
foreign
[Music]
wow is this actually my life and Nicole
is clearly proving she can do it all and
that work ethic she's got she told E.T
earlier this year her and hubby Keith
Urban are instilling that into their two
daughters I think they see it you know
they're firsthand where we travel as a
little group where always we share
pretty much everything I always say it's
our work as a family it's not my work
um so they share in everything all of
them because it is our work and without
their support I wouldn't be able to do
it
um and they're right there with me and
we have a very deeply intimate family so
we share a lot so you know they've both
seen a lot and been aware of a lot of my
goals and my husband as I've always said
is
I mean he is Rock Solid like just an
incredible love and support to me as I
hope I give to him as well
[Music]